mr president uh there has been articles
out
and i would assume that uh
joe biden and kamala harris not giving
their position on court packing
would be a national ad i assume them
both on record
saying they would ban fracking would be
an ad that would
run on a lot of cycles in ohio and
pennsylvania
uh their website that endorses the green
new deal and joe biden saying he would
spend trillions of dollars on it and
pledging
that what would the new green deal uh
look like in your view if implemented as
promised by both joe
uh biden and as a co-sponsor come with
kamala harris in the u.s senate
well it's a deal that was conceived of
by not smart people arc
plus three and others i don't even think
they had any experience in
the environment but this was a deal
conceived of
and the real price is 100 trillion
dollars that's more money that this
country could make
in a hundred years if things went well
okay
i mean they literally want to take
buildings down and rebuild them with
tiny little windows
okay little windows so you can't see out
you can't see the light
and the whole thing is so crazy it's
such a crazy thing
and take a look and biden
agreed to this with crazy bernie because
you know they have the manifesto they've
agreed to most of these things
and it's going to cost more money our
country will be
a ninth world country not a third world
country a ninth world country
we won't have energies look at what's
happening with the rolling blackouts in
california
look at where california is going to
have to rash in water you know why
because they send millions of gallons of
water out to sea
out to the pacific because they want to
take care of certain little tiny fish
that aren't doing very well without
water to be honest with you
but uh it's uh it's a very sad thing
that's happening it's no common sense
even the fires in california i
i talk about you need i i was with
governor newsom i get along with them
very well we disagree a lot of things
but i get along with them
number one you should let water come
down from the north
and accept it instead of throwing it out
to the pacific but you also
have to have forest management we send
them so much money i don't have to
but i want to help california but they
have the biggest forest fires
because they don't manage their land
they don't have separators
they have trees that have been laying on
the ground that are stone cold dead
dry like a matchstick
and you throw a cigarette butt on
between the leaves and the trees
everything catches on fire and you lose
two hundred thousand acres in a short
period of time
they gotta manage their forests manage
foreign
not see the forest fires